shooters everywhere  vanderbilt on the kickouts one man  just showing his versatility defensively  moving his feet so here's your guy  joshua  [Applause]  this is the play like you said  they've been running it and it's peyton  [Music]  steph thought about that  over again  just got a running start when he gets a  running start  he is cleared for takeoff  do not get in his way  karl anthony towns did  and he's paying the price  the jordan pool is three  [Music]  kill  mode just moving the ball getting out on  the break but andrew wiggins did not  give up on the play he got carlington  carl anthony towns twice like that  watch your head guard the towns  his teammates love it  fist pumping fans going crazy  he lit chase center up  now andrew wiggins  is so unassuming and so mild-mannered  but if you don't think when he plays  against minnesota